he was the longest serving consort
in history one of the last surviving
people in this country
to have served in the second world war
at cape matapan
where he was mentioned in dispatches for
and bravery the invasion of sicily where
he saved his ship
by his quick thinking and from that
conflict
he took an ethic of service that he
applied
throughout the unprecedented changes of
the post-war era
like the expert carriage driver that he
was
he helped to steer the royal family and
the monarchy
so that it remains an institution
indisputably vital
to the balance and happiness of our
national life
he was an environmentalist and a
champion of the national world
natural world long before it was
fashionable
with his duke of edinburgh awards scheme
he shaped
and inspired the lives of countless
young people
and at literally tens of thousands of
events
he fostered their hopes and encouraged
their ambitions we remember the duke
for all of this and above all for his
steadfast
support for her majesty the queen
not just as her consort by her side
every day of her reign but as her
husband
her strength and stay of more than 70
years
and it is to her majesty and her family
that our nation's thoughts must turn
today
because they have lost not just a much
loved and highly respected public figure
but a devoted husband and a proud
and loving father grandfather
and in recent years great grandfather
speaking on their golden wedding
anniversary her majesty said
that our country owed her husband a
greater debt
than he would ever claim or we
shall ever know and i'm sure that
estimate
is correct so we mourn
today with her majesty the queen we
offer our condolences
to her and to all her family
and we give thanks as a nation and a
kingdom
for the extraordinary life and work
of prince philip duke of edinburgh